Так звана "Кремлівська доповідь" зі списком
наближених до керівництва Росії чиновників та бізнесменів,
яку мають представити у США, схоже,
змусила Кремль нервувати.
У Москві наголошують: суспільство підтримує
зовнішню політику країни і змінити її
через тиск на еліти не вийде.
"Кремлівська доповідь" – має стати відповіддю Вашингтона
на дії Росії в Україні та ймовірне втручання Кремля
у президентські вибори
в США у 2016 році.
Імена тих, хто потрапив до списку, поки невідомі.
Але відомо, що це люди, наближені до російського президента,
а також члени їхніх родин.
Ось що сказав DW з цього приводу американський
сенатор-республіканець Марко Рубіо:
Путін скрізь розставив лояльних йому людей,
чиї доходи та рівень життя залежать від його бажання
дозволити їм стати бенефіціарами його правління.
Я думаю, з цієї доповіді стане ясно,
що є група наближених олігархів, які контролюють
національні багатства завдяки своїм стосункам з Путіним.
Вони ж, своєю чергою, є його
агентами впливу у світі, яких він
використовує для своїх політичних та фінансових цілей.
Кількість людей у кремлівському списку поки теж невідома.
Оцінки різних ЗМІ розходяться  - від 50
до кількох тисяч.
Більша частина доповіді має бути публічною, проте деякі
фрагменти залишаться засекреченими.
Оприлюднення списку наближених до Кремля не означає,
що проти них автоматично запроваджуються санкції,
але проблеми у них точно виникнуть, вважає Деніел Фрід,
екс-координатор з питань санкцій в Держдепі США
за часів Барака Обами.
Згадка у цьому списку збільшить ймовірність
потрапляння під санкції у майбутньому.
Думаю, якщо західні банки
та бізнес продовжуватимуть працювати з цими людьми,
у них виникнуть
іміджеві проблеми. Тому наслідки будуть,
але поки радше неформального характеру.
Чи запровадить адміністрація Трампа дійсно
санкції проти цих людей - це вже інше питання.
На думку західних експертів,
про те, що в Росії
дуже серйозно ставляться до "Кремлівської доповіді"
свідчать два факти. Зокрема, те,
що за останні місяці різко збільшилася кількість
заявок з Росії щодо надання громадянства Мальти.
А також те, що Путін торік двічі зустрічався
з провідними бізнесменами,
а не один раз наприкінці року, як зазвичай.
Неможливо бути мільйонером або мільярдером
в сучасній Росії без мовчазної згоди або мовчазної підтримки
Путіна. Він вирішує,
хто отримає гроші. І це прямо пропорційне
його можливостям тримати цих людей під контролем,
а саме - представляти його інтереси, бути його агентом
та не йти проти системи, де він себе бачить
як нового царя.
"Кремлівську доповідь" мають представити Конгресу США
29 січня. Якими будуть
конкретні кроки проти фігурантів доповіді, залежить
від адміністрації Дональда Трампа. Ймовірно, це може
бути замороження фінансових активів,
заборона на в’їзд до США або заборона
на співпрацю з ними.